and and let's get to
the news of the day which kind of came
out of the blue peter but you had
something in football morning in america
a week and a half ago saying this could
happen and happen it has
for
the third time in his career brandon
cooks has been traded he was a first
round pick in 2014 traded for a first
round pick in 2017 traded for a first
round pick in 2018 now he's only traded
for a second round pick cooks along with
a 20-22 fourth-rounder goes from the
rams to the texans peter your reaction
when you saw the news
well mike brandon cooks uh clearly has
had one of the strangest careers in nfl
history and that is not hyperbole just
consider this he's drafted 20th overall
and in the intervening time over the
last over the last four years
brandon cooks has been traded
three times
for the 32nd pick in the draft for the
23rd pick in the draft and now for the
57th pick in the draft this guy's 26
years old mike and teams right now have
spent
three first-round picks and a second
round pick in trading him three times
since he was drafted so it's absolutely
crazy
i will just say a couple of things
about why i believe this happened and
you're right mike a week and a half ago
i wrote about the possibility that
brandon cooks would be traded two nfl
teams reached out to me
in the in the 24 hours after that one
saying it's absolutely not going to
happen because the rams want too much
and the other saying
what would be your gut feeling the
bottom line as to what gets this done
and at the time my feeling was that if
you offered in the range of about the
60th pick in the draft that was going to
get the rams interested and now
because it lasted another week or so and
they definitely wanted to get this done
before the draft
you know i think the rams basically said
okay we'll throw in a four you know a
future four
and to in order to be able to get this
done so
the rams now have more ammunition
because what the rams need to do right
now the rams have to stock up on younger
low-cost players on their team mike
because as you know their cap situation
is onerous that's one of the reasons why
they were driven to get rid of cooks
and number two obviously the houston
texans the houston texans needed this
after getting rid of deandre hopkins
and let's start with the texans because
from their perspective they move deandre
hopkins there's a flip-flop of fourth
round picks texans send theirs this year
get back the cardinals next year but
they get david johnson and a second
round pick a higher second round pick
than the one they sent to brandon cook
so they send a lower second round pick
for brandon cooks they come out of it
with david johnson an upgraded second
round pick and brandon cooks
i don't know that that that that
replaces de'andre hopkins because i
don't know
that brandon cooks is in the same
stratosphere as deandre hopkins i don't
think he is he definitely wasn't last
year 14 games less than 600 receiving
yards brandon cooks was largely a
non-factor last year and you throw on
top of it peter he's had four
concussions since he was knocked out
cold during super bowl 52 as a member of
the new england patriots when he was hit
by malcolm jenkins four concussions in a
relatively short period of time that is
a huge red flag so i don't know that the
texans should feel good about this i
almost feel like the texans reacted to
the intense criticism of trading to
andre hopkins and decided we better go
get a veteran receiver let's go find one
anywhere we can to placate our fans to
placate the media and maybe to placate
quarterback to sean watson
well mike we've talked about it on this
show several times about the strength of
the receiving class in this draft i want
you just to think of in
2019 in the draft the the draft was very
strong at wide receiver so strong the dk
metcalf who played like a first rounder
was picked 64th overall
and so strong that terry mclaren in
washington who was the 76th pick in the
draft also played like a first rounder
in 2019 so it's going to be very
interesting to see
i have already written myself a note
mike on things to follow in the draft
what receivers were available
at pick number 57
and i'm going to be paying very close
attention to that because look that's
how this trade is going to be measured
you took uh you sent basically the 57th
pick in the draft to be able to get
uh
brandon cooks so on the board at that
time what receivers this is a
stocked a stacked
uh draft for wide receivers so to me
what are you going to be giving up that
you could have had in the draft and
that's going to be the most interesting
thing to watch i think for the houston
texans in this draft
consider this ravens gm eric decosta
said yesterday that we think this year
there's a really good chance to get a
guy that can probably be a starter at
receiver in the fifth round
of the draft so again a curious move by
the texans and their coach slash gm bill
o'brien to give up that pick number 57
to get brandon cooks and his 8 million
salary that's already fully guaranteed
now let's flip it over to the rams
perspective you mentioned the fact that
they need
young cheap talent because of their cap
situation well
compounding their cap situation is a 21
million dollar plus hit that they're
taking for trading brandon cooks they
held on to him long enough where they
had to pay him another four million
dollars in a roster bonus mid-march
because they hadn't traded him before
that money became due and all told 40.54
million for two seasons with brandon
cooks that peter the the rams right now
quietly are putting together some of the
worst contracts we've seen in recent
years from brandon cooks to the todd
gurley debacle to this jared goff ball
and chain they're carrying around
it's unbelievable to me how a team that
not that long ago was at the very top of
the nfc with kind of this vibe that
they're here to stay
these huge contracts are dragging the
rams down to the point where they've got
to do kind of a change the tire on a
moving car rebuild if they want to
continue to be competitive in the nfc
west
i think the
what you're talking about mike basically
happened
after you remember a year ago basically
that
uh that
when when sean mcvay was re-upped one of
the first things he said internally is
now i want to make sure that we keep
jared goff
and and it's clear
that his they were so fervent for jared
goff a year ago and who knows we'll see
if that pays off we'll see if that
contract works long term clearly
after golf's performance in
2019
there are questions about whether that's
going to be a smart long-term contract
or not so we'll see
but i believe that what happened with
the brandon cooks trade
uh when he was acquired from new england
they were very enthusiastic about
getting him they thought that he was
going to be a solid number one for the
next four or five years and i believe
and i've not talked to anybody there
since this trade happened last night but
i believe that their decisions with
brandon cooks
uh have been influenced they paid him
like a number one receiver and then he
wasn't won last year in part because of
his injury history so now going forward
the really interesting thing to see is
are they going to be able to develop
those low-cost players
uh that have been absolutely vital to
rebuilds of other really good teams in
the past and they're crucial to this
team because look at every other team
in the nfc west look at arizona rising
right now the 49ers are obviously going
to be good for a long time seattle's
always good the rams have to be really
really careful because they might be
might be in the most competitive
division in football right now
as frank costanzo once said i'm like a
phoenix rising in arizona and you're
right the cardinals on their way up in
the nfc west and the rams easily could
get left in the dust and peter number
one tailback gone with a contract that
was in hindsight a gigantic mistake and
the cook's deal was done sight unseen
they gave up the first round pick and
they paid him huge money again 40.54
million for two seasons of football that
was a huge mistake and as you said the
jared goff contract starting to look
like maybe it was a mistake too so who's
their number one receiver is he not on
the roster at this point
robert woods and cooper cup i would
think are the co number ones right now
be and and mike that's another issue
they love cooper cup and they're gonna
have to pay him too
um and and at some point
when you pay so many people at some
point a guy comes up to get paid and you
say
i love you
i wish we could pay you and we can't i'm
not saying that's going to happen with
cub
but they're gonna have to bite the
bullet pretty soon on a really good
player who they'd like to keep but they
just can't
yeah they should have done it with
with todd gurley in hindsight and they
still owe him some money from a roster
bonus that came due last month and i did
some more digging on that yesterday they
owe him money period and they haven't
paid it and they've leaked to espn.com
that they think they're in the right my
understanding is they are clearly in the
wrong so it is a strange time for the la
rams and the way they've been doing
business hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching make sure to hit subscribe
for the latest news and highlights from
nbc sports